it's fair to say that mixer wasn't as a
platform the size of twitch o-o it's not
even close the statistics are like they
get like five percent of the viewership
and and that wasn't what I was really
worried about I knew what I knew what it
was going to do for a lot of other
streamers and a lot of other gamers and
that was like that was like what I kept
telling myself in the back of my head
[Music]
ninja knew that leaving twitch would
forever change the streaming industry
he gave twitch a wake-up call and showed
them that their grip on the streaming
industry wasn't as strong as they once
thought over the last four months other
streamers followed ninjas lead finding
other platforms to sign up under and at
this point everybody is on the edge of
their seat waiting to see who's going to
leave next obviously you know mixer got
ninja they got shroud and who knows
who's next bro ninja ignited a war in
streaming a war fought on the
negotiations
[Applause]
20:19 has been the year of streamers
moving platforms the mixers in the
youtube gaming's of the world are
rushing to snap up twitches biggest
names in an effort to jumpstart their
own platforms a moment a facebook gaming
I'm going to be moving over to Facebook
gaming how many moves all of these
streamers followed in the footsteps of
ninja looking for big money elsewhere on
the flip side you finally have twitch
signing some of the remaining top dogs
like Tim the top man dr. Lupo and lyric
before they have the chance to peace out
hear that Kevin we're not going anywhere
I've officially resigned with twitch I
was on twitch and that's where I'm
staying the streamers that leave twitch
though well they're forced to make a
trade off yeah sure they gain big money
contracts but they also give up a large
chunk of their viewership I mean just
look at ninja I have one point ninja was
twitches biggest dreamer I mean he had
14 million followers and averaged 41,000
concurrent viewers every time he
streamed you can click on that subscribe
button in your go taco stream to click
on that purple rectangular subscribe you
can do the same on the jet stream what
was your would code it's a meal it's a
cold Mill it's a cold milk mil he even
streamed fortnight with Drake and Travis
Scott yeah I've been watching you I've
been watching your [ __ ] for a minute man
thank you man
ninja was the king of twitch but he left
that all behind I know this may come as
a shock to many of you but as of today I
will be streaming exclusively on mixer
ninjas first mixer stream was huge he
peaked at 85 thousand viewers but those
numbers wouldn't last now in December
just a few months later ninja averages
around 13,000 viewers per stream while
that would be incredible for most
streamers it's a big drop for him listen
I need you guys understand something man
if you guys are even thinking I'm
reading a couple of the comments I can
only assume you guys are talking about
my viewers how many understand how
little I give a [ __ ] okay how little
viewers beating me right now on
my jaw dive you man and guess what I get
to do it without having to worry about
my sub count for playing ads or ad
revenue I can take vacations I can take
time off I got my stream days I am
comfortable and ninja isn't alone in
feeling this way what these streamers
gave up in viewership they got in
boatloads of money
all of a sudden streaming isn't life or
death signing these big money contracts
allows streamers to take things like
vacations and not lose thousands of
dollars at the drop of a hat there's no
more of the of the fear of being tied
down just for a sub count button it also
lets them be more creative and take more
chances but my favorite part about being
here is I can play whatever the [ __ ] I
want and not have to feel so pressured
to play the game that everybody wants me
to play on the surface ninja moving to
mixer looks like one of the top
personalities cashing out while he's
still on top but for streamers
everywhere ninja's move is one of the
best things that could have happened to
the industry if you're a streamer that
has any sort of an audience right now
holy [ __ ] you were on cloud nine and
like you've got all these different
companies now they're trying to get into
the live streaming game and you're like
oh yeah well I could get 5 million here
3 million there 4 million in stock
options here it's like you've got all
these multi-billion dollar companies
fighting over your your audience an
industry that has struggled with
work-life balance and insane grinds for
years I was still attached to the stream
I was still thinking about the stream I
was still thinking about streaming the
next day or the day after that you know
if I was taking the next day off I was
always thinking about the next stream so
every day I took off this sticky hand
got stretchier and stretchier and
treachery until finally it actually
snapped off and I wasn't worried about
streaming the next day and it felt great
not only are the top streamers leaving
making tons of money but Twitch's also
on the clock to sign the remaining top
talent before they also jump ship and
look it doesn't matter that ninja isn't
pulling 40k viewers on every single
stream or the fact that he no longer has
twitches back
dude is still killing it as one of the
only streamers to really breakthrough
into the mainstream I need to learn how
to play so that's why I invited one of
the most popular players to come here
and teach me please welcome ninja but
when people remember ninjas moved to
mixer it won't be because of the money
he made or the shots that they threw at
twitch they'll remember the war that he
started in the thousands of streamers
that he benefited along the way thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages